I'm in the kitchen with fellow actress and foodie,
Sienna Miller!
Who I love so much!
And I am going to learn a recipe of hers.
You're in the driver's seat.
I'm in your car, baby, take it away.
What are we making?
So it's very English, it's a roast beef.
The is beef, and then you stuff little bits of garlic
into these premade holes.
Premade holes, garlic.
Yes, you can shove it in.
Oh, I see it.
Yes, and then you can rub it
with the salt and pepper and some thyme.
Sort of rub that in, mhmm.
Can also be like,
"You bad boy."
Naughty.
(Sienna and Drew laughing)
Sorry.
I'll leave you, I'll let you have a moment.
And then you rub-rub,
and then you can flip, get in there.
Oh, she likes her salt, I do too.
Ooh, it does make a good sound.
Don't they call it like a rump roast?
A rump roast, yeah.
(audience clapping)
(hands slapping roast)
Ah, that's too good.
Okay, so then that's that.
And then, we're gonna put that in the oven.
Perfect, okay,
let me open the oven for you.
Can you do that now?
Thank you, darling.
So teamwork makes the dream work.
It does indeed.
You put the roast in the oven.
Oh, it's a beautiful piece of beef.
There we go.
And then, we're gonna do roast potatoes,
which obviously there's not a proper roast
if there aren't roast potatoes.
So you've got the oil?
I do.
That's vegetable oil and olive oil,
you have to add some butter.
Of course you do.
And then, you parboil the potatoes.
So here's one we made earlier.
Yeah, normally I would heat that up first
so that then when you put them in it goes tss.
So remember that.
Oh, so this should be like boiling.
It can be boiling.
Oh.
And then, you have little burns all over you.
Look, there are cooking burns.
Oh my god,
you do have little burns.
And this is slightly tipsy the other day
trying to make a ham sandwich when I got home.
Oh, been there!
We've all been there.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, so that was that wound.
So would we put this in the oven then as well?
We'd put this in the oven,
and then you wanna cover it with all that like yum.
Oh my god.
Basically, it's called a roast potato,
but I put so much oil and butter
in there that it basically fries the potato.
It's like ginormous french fries.
'Cause I'm looking at the end result
and I'm dying over there.
And then, a bit of that.
Pinch of salt, and then will you
open the door for me?
I'll get the oven for you.
Perfect.
Oh my god, I love cooking with you.
This is so nice.
Perfect, the potatoes are in.
And then, we have a creamy leek and a gravy.
The gravy is essential.
This is the creamy leek.
Mmm, yum-yum.
It's like a bechamel of num-nums.
And then, this gravy,
it's kind of like a family recipe this.
It's pretty delish.
I love leeks so much.
I love gravy.
I always wanna just like drink it as a soup.
Oh my god.
Ah, so good.
And those leeks,
the creamy leeks.
Can you stand it?
Are incredible.
Do you want some
on your plate?
I really do!
All of these steps and tips,
and the complete navigational culinary map
will be on our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
And, yeah, potatoes.
You want these.
You've got your eye on them.
I do.
By the way, you know me.
I was literally like.
You can barely focus.
"I gotta get those potatoes on the plate."
Look at them.
They call me the seagull.
I heard that.
It's true.
I heard it.
And I was seagulling
for those potatoes.
You might have met your match with a fellow seagull.
I mean, I love the gravy.
I love to like have it swimming.
I don't know how much.
Gravy, gravy.
Gravy me, please.
Gravy me, girl.
Gravy me, baby.
I want you to slap that beef again.
I'm gonna wake up laughing.
By the way, I was just about to say,
when I'm like hitting the pillow tonight
and drifting off to sleep.
Yeah, you're gonna giggle.
I'm gonna giggle about you and me.
(audience clapping)
Such a perfect sound, oh.
This is one gorgeous,
gorgeous plate of food.
I know.
Oh, Sienna Miller,
everybody go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com website.
Oh, that's so good!
Mm, oh my god.
Oh my god.
My eyes just crossed.
(audience cheering)
These are really good, I'm freaking out.
Incredible.
I need to try that.
I have to say,
get your plate of food,
get your bottle of wine,
get whatever it is that's your accoutrements
that you like to settle in,
because when you pick up that remote control
and you start watching this show,
you're not going to be able to stop.
It's so good, it's best in class.
It's "Anatomy of a Scandal."
It's available April 15th on Netflix,
and you're gonna really enjoy the ride.
It's incredible.
Thank you.
Sienna, so are you.
(upbeat music)